Gary I've got a very serious question
for you hey Brian how the do you get
away with saying so many times on stage
and not catch a bunch of [__] black for
it Brian as the CEO of an upand
cominging IPO company uh I'm very
impressed with your audacity to ask that
question which uh leads to my very
simple answer which is twofold I think
the reason I get away with dropping the
f bomb is number one I mean it when I
say it there's no tactic I'm uh I'm just
in the zone I mean I was inspired by
Richard prior and Chris Rock and Eddie
Murphy and their Styles have translated
to my keynote Styles I feel like I do a
little bit of a standup timing process
and I think that because I'm not forcing
it and because it's my natural Zone
little Jersey Boy action people respect
authenticity the other reason I'm able
to get away with it is I don't care if I
receive Flack as a matter of fact I use
the f bomb to vet people let me you know
I've said it before and I'm going to say
it again we're going to do it again and
question coming up this is a platform
for me for the hardcore last seven years
fans of mine for me to go one layer
deeper into things I've never said
before the truth is I actually use my
F-bomb to vet other people I actually
react to the way you're reacting to my
fbom because if you are a person back to
the last question that is so thrown off
by using the fbom in public in a public
setting with a keynote that you're then
not looking at big enough picture for me
just my personally you're judging me I'm
judging you so if you are incapable of
getting over that and seeing the bigger
statement that I'm creating well then
you're not going to be somebody that I
want to do business with invest in or
take on as a client to begin with
because you're at this micro level
that's right you're at this micro level
and that's just not a place where I want
to play I don't want to play in the
micro so
you